[Musique]
bonjour monsieur le ministre un jour
merci d'accueillir france 24 et rfi au
quai d'orsay rebonds kobe mystère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères est
à mes côtés christophe boisbouvier de
rfi monsieur le ministre bonjour alors
en ukraine les russes ont annoncé hier
qu'ils allaient réduire radicalement
leurs activités militaires autour de
kiev et de czerny give dans le même
temps il ya les négociations qui se
passent en turquie et qui semble avancer
alors il y a quelques mois monsieur le
ministre vous disiez et que le pire
était devant nous est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous êtes plus optimiste est ce que vous
voyez une éclaircie non non dans la
mesure où pour l'instant la guerre
continue je lui des propos je lis les
déclarations je ne vois pas date il n'y
a à ma connaissance aucune mesure de
retrait qui étaient prises à l'égard de
l'occupation par les forces armées
russes en ukraine la guerre continue à
kiev ait eu des bombardements cette nuit
la guerre continue à nier prologue a
continué à
kharkhiv la guerre continue à marioupol
qui devient une ville martyre où le
siège de marioupol décidée par le
président poutine abouti à ce qui y est
près de 200000 personnes qui sont prises
en otage la guerre continue et pour
l'instant il n'y a à ma connaissance ni
percée ni nouveautés vous faites
référence à des déclarations il ya eu
beaucoup de déclarations de la part des
autorités russes de manière très
variable et pour l'instant il prenait
non plus nous ne me croyez pas je
croirai que les as tu es quand si demain
matin le président poutine dit comme
signe de ma volonté de ré articulations
de réorganisation je renonce au siège de
marioupol jeu permet à l'aide
humanitaire de rentrer dans marioupol
jeu permet à la population civile de
millau paul de circuler librement alors
là je dirais ah oui il ya un progrès et
là je dirais oui peut-être que le pire
n'est pas devant nous mais aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas d'acte vous de vous dit
comment tony blinken le secrétaire
d'état américain il n'ya il y à ce que
la russie dit et ce qu'elle fait donc
vous n'avez pas confiance en vérité en
vladimir poutine la confiance et les
actes ç'a toujours été des zap la
confiance est donc pour l'instant ils ne
sont pas au rendez vous et on y est il
naïf de croire un cessez le feu ils font
un cessez le feu mais le cessez le feu
il se décrète pas il sait répond à une
décision politique du président poutine
de dire ok on arrête et on négocie pour
l'instant ce n'est pas le cas et vous
parlez négociations c'est vrai qu'il ya
eu un événementiel autour des
négociations de d'istanbul mais les
discussions ils ont commencé déjà depuis
trois semaines elle se faisait au mieux
le russie à gomel se faisaient aussi son
fer et antalya en partie mais sur les
mêmes sujets avec moins de côté
spectaculaire mais pour l'instant rien
n'a avancé sur aucun sujet
donc voilà quelle est la réalité dont il
faut pas se faire d'illusions départ du
déclaratif il faut des actes et si la
russie veut vraiment qu'on croit en elle
qu'elle met des actes sur la table et
qu'elle le concrètement qu'elles
manifestent cette nouvelle orientation
s'il y en a une mais est ce que les
russes ne vont tout de même pas
desserrer l'étau autour de kiev
peut-être pour redéployer plus à l'est
de l'ukraine dans le dombass et donc
déshabiller le nord pour habiller
l'instant là on verra pour l'instant sur
des annonces je constate lequel a été
bombardé cette nuit vous ne craignez pas
une concentration de troupes russes sur
le d'ambassade il est possible que vu
les difficultés qu'à l'armée russe en
ukraine et des plans soient réévalués
mais il est possible aussi que cette
période où on annonce des discussions
plus approfondies
soit une période qui soit mise à profit
par la russie pour reconstituer ses
forces parce que savait la stratégie de
guerre des sièges qui s est stratégique
et mises en oeuvre aujourd'hui par la
russie le siège de deux karkhiv le siège
de marioupol ailleurs oui je ne vais
annoncer la gardie série garneau sic et
l'égard des guerres de siège sont
terribles on a une histoire des guerres
des sièges l'histoire c'est à la fois
grosse ni et puis et puis alep où on a
vu je pense à à l'aide parce que j'ai
été en responsabilité à ce moment là où
on a vu la russie dit bon on va négocier
et puis en fait la réalité c'était pour
vous constituer des forces donc on va
voir on va voir si le discours qui est
tenu va se manifester dans des actions
concrètes et donc
soit dans des retraites soit dans
l'annoncé d'un cessez le feu ce qu'il
faudrait aujourd'hui c'est l'annoncé
d'un cessez-le-feu un barrio paul pour
éviter le carnage parce que ce qui se
passe à mario pâle et effroyable et donc
la responsabilité de ce qui va se passer
à marioupol c'est la responsabilité de
la russie vous parlez des négociations a
abordé le sujet militaire et le sujet
diplomatique alors pour la première fois
depuis enfin vous disais depuis trois
semaines les négociations ont avancé les
eyzies craignant renoncerait à intégrer
le temps et accepterait un statut de
neutralité mais à condition que des
grands pays dans comme la france
garantissent leur sécurité alors
concrètement mais jamais ni ça veut dire
quoi être garant parce que pardonnez moi
ça ressemble furieusement à l'article 5
de l'otan du traité de l'otan qui dit
une attaque contre un c'est une attaque
contre tous vous avez dit les
négociations avancées elles n'ont pas
avancé non elles sont stables mais
négociation sur les mêmes sujets oui
sont abordés régulièrement par les
délégations russe et les délégation
ukrainienne depuis trois semaines avec
une avance est un acte politique lourd
qui était posée par le président et lens
qui consiste à dire moi je suis d'accord
pour qu'on travaille sur un concept de
neutralité de l'ukraine oui mais
jeudi en même temps au delà de la
neutralité dont il faut définir le
contenu mon l'instant ce n'est pas le
cas il me faut des garanties de sécurité
ce qui est normal donc posons le
réfléchissons garanties de sécurité et
pour l'instant il n'ya pas d'acceptation
ni du premier principe ni du second il
faudrait peut-être réfléchir déjà est ce
que ça veut dire nous sommes tout à fait
disponible pour travailler avec le
président abbas qu'il le sait sur la
manière d'assurer des garanties mais le
problème c'est qu'il faut une vraie
négociation et il serait peut-être porta
aussi que le président et nas qui
rencontre le président poutine ne
serait-ce que cela pour l'instant ce
n'est pas possible puisque le présent
quand il le refuse et ses garanties de
sécurité le président sénat ce qui ne
l'est demanderait pas pour la crimée
pour le thon basse est ce à dire ben que
peut-être dans l'avenir un rattachement
de ces deux régions à la russie serait
envisageable et pourrait peut-être
permettre de régler les affaires moi je
ne vais pas négocier à la place des
ukrainiens c'est aux ukrainiens de
négocier avec la russie on connaît les
sujets de négociation
neutralité garantie niveau de
démilitarisation de l'ukraine tel de
l'ukraine territoire qu'elle statue sur
le don basse et la question de la crimée
avec en plus de ça la nécessité d'un
cessez le feu à quel moment et la
nécessité aussi d' un agenda de retrait
progressif des forces russes c'est tout
ça le paquet de négociations mais ça
fait trois semaines que c'est tout ça
est pour l'instant à part le président
s'est inscrit la seule initiative forte
qui a été prise c'est celle par laquelle
il a annoncé sa volonté de faire en
sorte que l'ukraine devienne un pays
notre n'est-il pas naïf
ce mini de parler de neutralité quand on
est entouré par par la russie les
voisins vont cesser de garantie
et d'où la nécessité de négocier et on
ne négocie pas avec un revolver sur la
tempe donc d'où la nécessité d'un cessez
le feu et d'autre part vous voyez bien
que s'il y a une modification de la
constitution ukrainienne
parce que pour dire neutralité il faut
un référendum
peut-on faire un référendum en ukraine
alors que les forces russes sont
présentes sur le territoire non donc
faut négocier tout cela pour l'instant
n'a pas commencé nous souhaitons ça
avance ça va très loin nous souhaitons
qu'il y ait tous la nécessité d'un
cessez le feu
ça va être long mais on
commence à voir quelques qu'elle
pourrait des paramètres en tout cas le
président ukrainien a déjà quelques
idées sur le sujet encore faut-il parler
et aussi parlé avec le président poutine
d'où la nécessité d'ailleurs de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait en permanence indiens
qu'ils soient maintenues avec le
président poutine c'est la raison pour
laquelle le président macron le ghana
souvent au téléphone pour garder un
vecteur de dialogue pour garder un canal
et pour faire en sorte que le moment
venu on puisse se parler de manière
approfondie j'espère que ce moment
arrivera arrivera vite et qu'on va
éviter le carnage de mario paul ils
sortent à quoi le président macron quand
il a le président poutine au téléphone
les points de vue sont généralement dit
clairement
généralement avec beaucoup de clarté de
part et d'autre il se reparlent ça
avance peu mais au moins il ya canal de
discussion qui est potentiel et le
président macron parle aussi avec le
présent poutine parfois avec le
chancelier allemand donc il faut que le
présent poutine se rendent bien compte
qu'il a
dans cette discussion deux partenaires
qui sont prêts à encourager le dialogue
mais qui sont aussi ferme sur la
souveraineté de l'ukraine et qui
refusent le fait qu'un état agresse un
autre état comme ça se passe là
maintenant avec tous les douleurs tous
les souffrances que cela impose au top
l'ukrainien alors vous disiez les les
turcs sont peut-être une bonne nouvelle
les danses est dans ce magma terrible
les turcs sont au centre de la médiation
et emmanuel macron erdogan se sont parlé
récemment est ce que la brouille entre
la turquie et la france c'est fini quand
il s'agit de sauver des vies de
permettre la paix d'enrayer le processus
dramatiques devant lequel nous sommes
contents les histoires on essaye de
faire avancer les choses et toutes les
bonnes volontés sont bienvenues
le secrétaire-général de l'otan jens
stoltenberg
déclare qu'un recours des russes aux
armes chimiques est encore possible et
que cela aurait des conséquences massive
est ce que vous confirmez c'est une
crainte que vous avez
si si la russie utilise des armes non
conventionnelles de ce type et il faut
qu'ils s'attendent à des sanctions
massives très forte ils le savent on le
leur a déjà dit donc il faut qu'il
prenne en considération ces risques mais
on a vu en 2013 comment
quand des armes chimiques ont été
utilisés en syrie tout le monde les
américains ont regardé ailleurs est ce
que vous ne craignez pas que la même
chose se reproduise je pense que le
président poutine s'est rendu compte
d'une chose
c'est l'unité et la fermeté et de
l'union européenne de l'ensemble des
pays et de la relation transatlantique
la solidité de l'alliance est aussi la
volonté de l'ensemble de ces pays
d'aider l'ukraine très fermement
à la fois par des sanctions à la fois
par de soutien financier mais aussi par
la livraison d'équipements militaires il
sait cela donc c'est à lui d'apprécier
les risques mais c'est de sa
responsabilité pas de là notre livraison
d'équipements militaires y compris par
la france puis qui conclura la france
mais nous fournissons des équipements
militaires défensif mais les taux à
l'ukraine nous et puis tous les pays
européens quasiment des équipements les
taux oui bien sûr et si
des armes chimiques sont utilisés qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire il faut intensifier
les sanctions comme dit boris johnson
oui je voudrais pas la réponse
mais oui j'ai dit sanctions lourdes et
massive je vais pas vous les décrire sur
le drame de marioupol impossible de
convaincre vladimir poutine de faire ce
qu couloirs humanitaires
même source à il veut pas plier
le concept de couloirs humanitaires à la
mode russe
est un concept particulier qui s'intègre
dans la logique de la guerre des sièges
on en a fait l'expérience à grozny on a
fait l'expérience à alep on est en train
de crâne cette expérience là aussi à
marioupol c'est à dire je vous laisse un
couloir humanitaire ce qui passe d'un
couloir humanitaire vous allez venir en
russie
et ceux qui ne partent pas vous êtes
considéré comme ou des terroristes ou
des nazis puisque le terme a été utilisé
et donc c'est un prétexte supplémentaire
de renforcer les bombardements c'est ça
la logique militaire des couloirs
humanitaires à la mode russe nous ce que
nous voulons sur mario paul c'est un
cessez le feu levée du siège et un
acheminement libre de l'aide humanitaire
et une liste circulation des populations
à marioupol c'est le sujet du moment et
il ne faudrait pas être abusés par des
déclarations russes alors que la réalité
c'est le drame de mario peau lancement
est il envisageable que manuel macron se
déplacent soit stiev soit à moscou et on
a déjà montré avec beaucoup de force que
les initiatives de paix été prise quand
il le fallait avec les risques qu'il
faut les prendre il l'a montré en se
rendant à moscou dans l'état actuel des
choses la question ne se pose pas pour
se poser mais pour l'instant ce n'est
pas d'actualité
depuis le début de la guerre l'union
européenne fait bloc
mais l'allemagne est beaucoup plus
dépendante du gaz russe que la france
est ce que cette belle unité ne risque
pas de se fracturer sur la question des
sanctions et d'embargo la grande
nouveauté c'est que l'europe
d'aujourd'hui n'est plus la même que
celle qui fonctionnait avant le 24
février la grande nouveauté ce qu'il ya
eu un conseil européen exceptionnel à
versailles qui a entériné ce que l'on
appelle la jada de versailles dans
lequel les européens ont décidé ensemble
d'acquérir l'autonomie énergétique dans
les plus brefs délais avec des étapes
mais dans les plus brefs délais ce qui
suppose ailleurs aussi d'assurer
le renforcement de la transition
énergétique est adapté à la lutte contre
le changement climatique pour ne plus
dépendre d'eux
des énergies fossiles russe et ce
mouvement là il va être mise en oeuvre
dès cette année il se poursuivra pour
avoir des réponses pérennes et ça
concerne tous les pays y compris
l'allemagne qui a soutenu cette logique
alors il faut chercher d'autres
partenaires c'est pour ça que c'est la
première partie de ma question vous
étiez à doha au qatar où vous avez
annoncé que nous étions tout près
proches d'un accord sur le nucléaire
iranien quand vous dites proches c'est
vous compter en jours en moi en semaine
qu'est ce qui bloque encore entre
téhéran et washington
la grande
avancée
concernant le nucléaire iranien c'est
que nous sommes sur les bases d'un
accord
concernant les accords de viennent c'est
à dire ce que l'on appelle en termes
techniques logiciels payants à ça veut
dire que l'iran est prêt à renoncer à
l'accession à l'arme nucléaire
et que les sanctions qui était lié à la
course en avant de l'iran pour acquérir
l'armé nucléaire vont tomber nous sommes
d'accord sur le contenu quand je dis
nous c'est tout le monde c'est à dire à
la fois les européens à la fois l'iran
la fois la russie à la fois la chine est
à la fois les états unis qui ne sont
plus partie prenante mais quand donné
leur accord donc la signature est
imminente et et ça serait une très bonne
chose que l'on n'ajoute pas une crise de
la prolifération nucléaire à la guerre
qui existent aujourd'hui en ukraine il
reste à blocage qui n'est pas lié à cet
accord qui est indépendant qe2 liés à la
relation entre les etats-unis et l'iran
sur d'autres sujets sur un autre sujet
en particulier j'espère que l'on pourra
aboutir à régler cette affaire parce
qu'à ce moment là on signe tout de suite
est ce qu'il y à un risque de famine
dans certains pays du sud avec
la perturbation très grave du marché des
céréales et que peut faire la france est
ce qu'il ya des stocks et que peut faire
la france sur le pour empêcher la
famille il y à un risque réel
de pénurie alimentaire en particulier
dans les céréales fois le blé le maïs
tournesol parce que l'ukraine est un
grand producteur et que c'est difficile
aujourd'hui de cultiver en ukraine le
risque aussi est dû au fait que la
logistique les transports sont
maintenant très difficile à la fois pour
l'ukraine mais aussi pour la russie et
donc il ne faudrait pas là aussi se
faire abuser par un discours qui est
développée aujourd'hui par par les
russes selon lequel six lits à demain
des risques de famine c'est dû aux
sanctions ce n'est pas dû aux sanctions
c'est dû à l'occupation par les russes
de l'ukraine et on ne cultive pas
étendues de terres solde en présence de
forces militaires ce n'est pas possible
d'où des craintes majeures sur la
sécurité alimentaire d'un certain nombre
de pays je pense aux pays du
moyen-orient de l'afrique en particulier
et d'où l'initiative qu'a prise le
président de la république lors de la
réunion du g7 à bruxelles la semaine
dernière qui s'appelle l'opération farm
qui consiste à prendre des actions
prendre des initiatives pour dans trois
domaines différents d'abord dans le
domaine de la commercialisation pour
qu'il y ait plus de transparence plus de
fluidité sur les marchés et éviter le
stockage éviter la spéculation sur les
céréales
un dispositif un dispositif de
solidarité pour faire en sorte que les
pays les plus en difficulté puisse être
soutenue par des livraisons et en
particulier dans le haut doubs qu'ils
courtisent au stade c'est ça la question
c est que l'on permette au programme
alimentaire mondial de faire son travail
et de ne pas être soumis à la
spéculation et au stockage pour pouvoir
distribuer et puis aussi pour produire
davantage et tous les pays sont incitées
à le faire ce triptyque là il est majeur
il est initié par la france mais il est
repris aujourd'hui par l'union
européenne
pour que l'on puisse être totalement
solidaire et éviter ces risques qui sont
pas pour demain matin et qui sont
malheureusement pour après demain alors
monsieur le ministre nous allons parler
du mali les militaires de barkan plus
bagages après neuf ans de présente deux
présences 58 soldats français ont perdu
la vie les djihadistes sont toujours là
ils vont même gagné du terrain est ce
que vous diriez est-ce que vous avez un
sentiment d'amertume vous qui avez vécu
de cerval aabar cannes un sentiment tout
de même de gâchis et une forme
d'impuissance le gâchis les politiques
parce que on rappelle souvent
l'initiative de cerval à ce moment là
puis de barkan pour empêcher
les actions terroristes des groupes qui
sont organisées il faut quand même
rappeler à téléspectateurs et aux
auditeurs que les comptes terroristes
c'est à la fois des chais al qaïda ce ne
sont pas des groupes informels sont des
groupes qui ont des résonances des
organisations qui sont habitués à au
type de combat qu'il mène et nous avons
bien fait d'agir à ce moment là pour
protéger le mali nous avons bien fait
parce que l'enjeu
c'est la souveraineté et l'intégrité
c'était et c'est toujours la
souveraineté l'intégrité du mali et moi
la date à laquelle je ne fais référence
le plus c'est 2015
les accords d'alger parce qu'il ya une
base ya une solution il ya eu des
négociations il ya eu des discussions
qui ont abouti à ces accords que les
responsables maliens pour des tas de
raisons n'ont pas voulu mettre en oeuvre
ces accords d'alger il repose à la fois
sur la décentralisation
sur le désarmement
des groupes armés signataires de leur
inclusion dans les forces armées où les
forces de police malienne et sur le
développement les 3d
décentralisation des êtres des armements
et et développement et le début du
commencement étaient à peine visibles or
il y à ce texte qui est garantie par
d'abord les autorités algériennes et qui
sont garants de cette de cet accord ont
parlé tout à l'heure de garantie des
autorités algériennes ont la
responsabilité ils l'assument de mettre
en oeuvre ces accords mais pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de réponse du
côté du mali et puis ces accords d'alger
ont permis aussi la présence des forces
des nations unies sur le territoire
malien pour assurer leur mise en oeuvre
il est sur la table
tournon le depuis deux mois monsieur le
ministre les militaires maliens les
miliciens présumés du groupe russe
wagner sont rendus responsables par les
nations unies et human rights watch de
graves exactions dans le centre du mali
est ce que vous confirmez ou pas ces
informations tous les éléments que nous
avons y compris les ong qui ont enquêté
sur le sujet y compris les nations unies
montrent que finalement la présence de
wagner au mali c'est quoi c'est des
exactions
et la limitation des libertés publiques
vous en savez quelque chose ses savates
allusion à la suspension des émissions
de rfi et france 24 sur c'est le nouvel
nouvel autoritarisme et qui fait que la
junte au pouvoir est prise un peu en
otage aussi sur ces points-là par la
force la teneur donc wagner qui était
réputé devoir être une force de
libération c'est une force d'exactions
et de prédation et en plus ils se
servent sur les ressources propres du
mali c'est pour ça c'est très grave
le temps est compté il y a deux mois
l'ambassadeur de france à bamako a été
expulsé par les autorités maliennes qui
l'accusait de comploter contre elle
est-ce que tout dialogue avec bamako est
rompu ou est-ce qu emmanuel goita ou
est-ce que emmanuel macron pardon
parle avec le chef de la junte malienne
le colonel assimilant ce gouvernement
n'a aucune légitimité
c'est un gouvernement issu d'un coup
d'état et c'est un gouvernement qui pour
l'instant ne met pas en place les formes
de reconnaissance légitime qui pourrait
avoir du peuple malien nous travaillons
nous avec la cedeao qui organise
l'ensemble des états de la de la région
pour lutter contre le terrorisme parce
que ce qu'ils va se passer c'est une ré
articulations complète
dispositif français et du dispositif
européen et que la décision de ré
articulations de repositionnement de
réorganisation a été prise par les
européens et par les africains ensemble
au mois de février dernier pour
organiser différemment c'est une
vraiment une refonte et pour donner
aussi une plus grande amplitude à notre
action commune en soutien aux
différentes autorités des pays concernés
par la menace terroriste non seulement
les pays du sahel mais désormais aussi
les pays du golfe de guinée puisqu'on
voit des des percées une porosité de
l'action des groupes terroristes dans la
norme cpi alors la france va se
redéployer au niger on a vu une
violentes manifestations anti-françaises
à tera en novembre dernier au passage
d'un convoi militaire de barkan trois
morts chez les manifestant-es qu'au
niger on ne risque pas de se heurter aux
mêmes problèmes qu'au mali c'est à dire
un sentiment anti français non c'est pas
du tout comme ça que va se passer
la france va pas se redéployer au niger
ce que je viens de dire c'est que nous
nous réorganisons ensemble quand j'ai
dit nous sont les européens et les
africains pour faire en sorte que les
quatre piliers de ce qu'on appelle les
accords djamena c'est à dire à la fois
la lutte contre le terrorisme le la
formation des forces militaires des pays
concernés le retour de l'état dans les
zones qui sont reconquise et le
développement je vais à madrid lundi
prochain pour assister à la troisième
réunion de l'alliance pour le sahel pour
mobiliser les fonds pour pour ces pays
nous allons nous réorganiser en fonction
des besoins et des demandes de chacun
des états concernés que ce soit au sahel
où les états de gaulle du golfe de
guinée avec des réponses variable selon
selon les différents pays et
solidairement les européens et les
africains donc c'est pas la france se
réinstalle au niger s'est passé au niger
il y aura une demande oui
souvenez européenne européenne
européenne peuvent y a trois fois merci
monsieur le ministre de nous avoir
accordé cet entretien et merci à vous de
nous avoir suivi sur nous deux une
france 24 et radio france internationale
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]